hey everyone its sales ready Turner
saurian calm and in this video I'm going
to go over how to assess the deep tendon
reflexes what I'm going to do for you in
this video is I'm going to go over a
short overview on how to assess a deep
tendon reflexes as a nursing student or
nurse then I'm going to show you how to
individually assess the following deep
tendon reflexes the bicep the triceps
the brachioradialis the patellar and the
Achilles and in order to do this you
will need a reflex hammer and this is
what a common reflex hammer looks like
so you may be asking yourself what is
the purpose why do we even assess the
deep tendon reflexes well the D tendon
reflexes help us to evaluate the lower
motor neuron / v or fibers at specific
levels in the body so what that means is
say your intake your reflex hammer and
you're in assess the brachioradialis
tendon this tells us how the spinal
nerve root C 5 - c 6 is working is it
working appropriately or the triceps
that you're going to hit on the tricep
tendon it tells us how C 7 - c 8 is
working and I'll go over those
individually whenever I show you how to
do them now as nurses whenever we are
completing our assessments or head to
toe assessments this is generally
conducted during the neuro assessment
part and depending on what specialty you
work in as a nurse you will do this a
lot more routinely than compared to
other specialties now in nursing school
you're going to have to learn how to do
this probably get checked off by your
professor in eliciting responses and
those five deep tendon but as a nurse
you're not going to do as commonly as
you are like listening to the lungs
every nurse is going to listen to all
their patients lungs but not necessarily
check their deep tendon reflexes
branson's neuro settings and labor and
delivery settings are probably going to
use this skill a lot more than compared
to a will say cardiac nurse because just
to give you an idea in labor and
delivery you have pregnant women and
pregnant women are at risk for
preeclampsia so one of the signs and
symptoms
so preeclampsia is hyperactive deep
tendon reflexes so you're enough as a
nurse you're going to be checking those
deep tendon reflexes if that's happening
and also on these women sometimes get
magnesium sulfate because of these
conditions and you want to be also
checking those deep tendon reflexes now
we talked about in the electrolyte
videos you know with some of the
electrolyte imbalances you can have
diminished e tendon reflexes so say you
are working on a med-surg floor and your
patient has really low electrolyte
levels you or high electrolyte levels
you'd want to check those deep tendons
to make sure you have a baseline
compared to before so all of a sudden
are diminished how were they whenever
you assess them earlier so that is why
we want to do this as nurses now and for
documentation purposes whenever you do
assess your deep tendon reflexes you use
a grading scale now whenever you're
checking deep tendon reflexes you need
to practice this skill over and over
because you have to understand what
hyper reflexive versus hyporeflexia
business because this skill is really
subjective and it takes practice to
understand it so let me go over how you
would grade okay a four plus this is
what is super really active this is the
highest score you can get is considered
hyperactive or clonus next is a three
plus this is where it's brisker than
normal it's considered hyperreflexia
reflexive and two this is where you want
the patient this is normal so hopefully
your patient is scoring a two plus and
one plus is diminished they're not very
reflexive and you would consider this
hypo reflexive and zero a score of zero
means they're completely absent you get
no response at all so now let's go over
these five deep tendon reflexes and show
you how to elicit response in one now
it's elicit the responses of the deep
tendon reflexes okay a lot of people
whenever you're first starting out they
have trouble eliciting a response so
some tips whenever you are going to get
that tendon to respond you want to make
sure you swing your hammer nice and
brisk not too slowly not too fast Lee
make sure you move it back because you
don't want the
in order to rest on the tendon after you
hit because you're not going to get the
response you want also you want to make
sure that you're hitting a tendon a lot
of people whenever they're beginning
they really don't know what they're
hitting and what you're hitting is the
tendon of that particular muscle so
always make sure you're finding that and
a good way to get to find that tendon is
have to have the patient flex the muscle
and you can feel a cord like area which
is the tendon of where you're supposed
to hit so the first one we're going to
hit is the bicep tendon okay the first
tendon reflex we're going to check is
the bicep tendon and the bicep tendon is
located below the bicep muscle in the
antecubital fossa area if you're
beginning out what you want to do is you
want to find that tendon so to find the
tendon we are going to have the patient
flex the arm and flex the bicep and you
will find it right in there and it feels
like a cord like area and whenever you
find it just put your thumb over it and
this is going to elicit the response of
c5 to c6 so I have my thumb over the
tendon area and I'm going to have him
relax the muscle and just drape his
forearm over his lap and then I'm just
going to hit with my hammer briskly and
what you're looking for is contraction
of the bicep and flexion of the forearm
and we had a little bit of a response
and there we go okay now let's do the
tricep okay now we're going to check the
tricep deep tendon and it is located on
the back of the arm right above the
elbow and if you're just new you're
trying to find it what you can do is
just extend the arm out and you can feel
just right above the elbow that deep
tendon so what you're going to do is you
want this whole area to be relaxed so
we're going to help the patient dangle
their arm tell them to let it go limp
and this is going to check c7 to c8 what
we're going to do is we're going to take
the hammer and just briskly hit on that
deep tendon and what you'll see is
extension of the forearm and a slight
contraction of the tricep so here we go
and seeing that seen that flex and that
contract it one more time there we go
now let's check our brachial
brachioradialis okay we're going to
check the brachioradialis deep tendon
and this is checking c5 to c6 this can
be one of the most difficult tendons
applying because it's not as pronounced
as the other tendon so what you want to
do is you want to find the radial
styloid process which is the nodule on
the wrist and go about two to three
centimeters above that how the patient
turn where their thumbs up word relaxing
the floor and resting it on their leg
we're going to right above that and what
we're looking for is for the hand to sup
innate which the palm will turn out
upward and you will see a little bit of
flexion in the forearm okay you notice
that right there okay now let's check
our patellar and our Achilles okay to
check the patellar reflex this is going
to be looking at l2 to l4 and to find
the tendon what you want to do is locate
the kneecap and then go just a little
bit right below it and the best way is
to have the patient extend the leg out
and then that tendon will pop out and
that is where you're going to go okay
after locating the tendon put your hand
behind the knee just to support it have
them relax and the tendon is right here
and what you're going to do is you're
just going to tap briskly and what we're
looking for is this lower leg to extend
outward so here we go
and we've got a response there and one
more time and got a really good response
there okay now let's check the Achilles
Achilles is going to look for l5 to s2
and this is best done having the patient
dangle their feet just like whenever
you're checking the patellar you usually
want to check those two together and
what you're going to do is you're going
to Dorse dorsiflex the foot up like that
and you will see the tendon which is
located right above the heel and it's
right there and what we're going to do
is we're looking for the fit to plantar
flex so it's going to go down like that
too
response but in order to do it you're
going to dorsiflex the foot by
supporting your hand underneath it and
just tapping the bottom of it
and flex melodeon okay so that is how
you check the deep tendon reflexes
please be sure to check out my other
nursing skill videos and consider
subscribing to this YouTube channel
thank you so much for watching